[Music]
seven deadly sins oh mike
even worse actually let me put i'll put
toradora there instead
seven deadly sins man just look at how
its ratings have decreased on my anime
list it
it honestly it was really interesting in
the first season of me i watched it i
mean years ago
so i might have been really young and
just thought it was interesting just
because i was kind of stupid
but as the show progressed the following
seasons just got worse and worse i don't
even know why it's still being animated
at this point like who's watching this
yeah i really do not like seven deadly
sins
parasite the maxim great show i've made
a video analyzing the main character
before check that out if you haven't
it's actually
a really old video so i might sound
weird in it but
and a lot of that stems from the fact
that i love shows with deeper
philosophical me
deals with really great dark themes has
awesome action
just really it's an easy top 10 for me
steins gate
i mean this is my favorite anime of all
time it's a masterpiece there's nothing
else i can really say about it
ams scientist
another another is
another
[Music]
another's all right no it's it's not
good
look another is a classic horror anime
but a lot of the time it's scory
just for the sake of being gory it
deserves recognition for being
one of the most popular and one of the
most classic horror anime
of all time i mean it's the first that i
ever watched
but it's really not much deeper than a
generic horror movie you can't read much
into it
[Music]
oh and we've only got goodies left in
here oh man
okay your name i've got some beef with
your name
look it's it's a good movie it's great
the animation is awesome the plot's
interesting the romance is cute
but for years it was the number two
anime on my anime list above shows like
stein's gate
legend of the galactic heroes gintama
which i just found completely absurd and
i still do
and thankfully now it's dropped way
lower because i mean there's just no way
your name should even be considered as a
competitor to full metal outcomes
brotherhood which is of course
goaded so yeah your name
it's just good don't over hype it guys
[Music]
and speaking of top 10 movies we've also
got koi no katachi a silent voice
which i'd put in the same category as
your name
it personally didn't hit me as hard as
your name did but it had a really
interesting premise and shows that deal
with bullying always stand out to me
it was really touching and actually
let's put it in great
yeah i think it was great demon slayer
demon slayer is demon slayer is good
i mean i've made a huge video about this
so i really don't want to explain here
but
i mean it's a good show i wouldn't put
it as far as great or goaded at least
season one i wouldn't i think season two
and further have potential for that
but season one it has a nice place here
in the good category
death parade not very good
episodic kind of boring honestly to me
the opening was an absolute banger
[Music]
and the easter egg with light from death
note was pretty interesting at the time
when i first watched this but
i mean other than that it uh it's not a
standout
one piece look if you're not watching
one piece if you're on that
oh it's too many episodes i don't have
the patience oh i don't like the art
style it's a turn off for me
grow up guys come on one piece is about
to become the best selling series of all
time over harry potter
and oh look that's just the manga i know
but the anime i mean it's incredible
guys one piece is absolutely iconic and
you should get on board before it ends
i mean it's not ending anytime soon but
better sooner than later
[Music]
assassination classroom also absolutely
great the ending
super touching just incredible story
dealing with the relationship between a
teacher and his students there's not a
lot of anime that do this
and it's just a really creative take on
this with you know the supernatural
element and the fact that it's
well an assassination classroom that
he's teaching that
i really love this show it's great
haikyuu
it's uh it's good well okay god people
are gonna come after you for this but
look look
there's a limit to how high a sports
anime can go in my opinion
there are so many tropes that can be
reused and redone in sports anime and
that
always are and of course there are
unique traits that each one can have
haikyuu having more than most actually
but to me it really can't get to that
goated category just because sports
anime can't get to that really deep
level that
shows in this goated category do
really deep level that deep level that
really deep level that shows in this
voting category and honestly i wouldn't
put any sports anime above this
other than probably slam dunk which i
think i would put in great
one punch man one punch man's alright
i mean it's the show that i would
recommend for someone who has never
watched anime before
but if there were someone who had
already watched a ton of anime but
somehow never watched one punch man
and they asked if i wanted to recommend
it to them i mean it wouldn't be the
first show i tell them to watch
it's interesting it's entertaining it's
certainly fun i actually read the manga
so something definitely stuck with me at
least but
it really doesn't stand out for me and
if it's in your top 10 then
i don't know what to say konosuba
konosuba is good it's funny it's a nice
comedy anime isekai
it's got really interesting and dynamic
characters
my hero hmm
i think my hero is great look this might
sound basic of me but i think starting
in season 3
my hero turned a new leaf for itself
season 1 was pretty generic it didn't
stand out much and season 2 even though
it improved on that still didn't stick
out to me in the way it should have
but season three had some really great
arcs it had deku vs
that dude with all the muscles actually
i think his name is muscles
it had all might verse all for one it
had deku vs bakugo
i mean there were just so many
absolutely incredible moments in season
3 and i've continued to read the manga
and i know it actually does
keep getting better and actually darker
from here on out
so it's got a really great future
spirited away
i mean it's a classic i mean you really
can't complain about this
it was the number one selling movie in
all of japan up until mugen trained past
it from demon slayer
mob psycho if it were just season one
i'd put it in good
but with season two i would put mob
psycho in goaded
i mean for me it's really hard to
explain what mob psycho has because it
tackles so many different things
great action slapstick humor power ups
sad moments crazy moments it's all
just really interesting to me and season
2 just improved on season 1 in just
about every single way possible
death note death note's good you talk to
anyone about death note and
spoiler alert almost unanimously people
will say
oh yeah it was really good up until l
died which is
i mean it's the case the show was really
great but then after l died it kind of
just lost its footing
elle was replaced by near who i mean he
was kind of interesting but
really just paled in comparison to l
and so the rivalry between light and l
which was certainly one of the most
important dynamics of the show
just disappeared and i don't know it
just went from a really great almost
goaded show probably to just good
and a kamega kill uh the ending kinda
sucked
fair enough so yeah this is my list this
was oh my god this was a long list to
make
and actually i have more shows in goaded
than i thought i would
but i mean i guess that's just a
testament to the fact that this is the
50 most popular shows on my anime list
so i mean i would hope that a lot of
them are really good
but that's it for the day what do you
guys think i'm sure there's a lot of
disagreements but just know i mean
i did this for entertainment i thought
it'd be fun and i really just wanted to
get my opinions on a lot of anime to you
guys
leave a comment below on what you think
as always this has been the anime
culture